okay thank you everyone for your
Indulgence apologies for the amount of
time that that has taken
um
I okay we'll move now to the debate and
we will start off I'll ask visiting
members I believe James Newport uh as
Ward member who would like to
speak thank
you thank you
chairman um good evening members
um so I didn't um make myself um
familiar with with the information that
you've just had and I will proceed with
um the views that um I've taken from
reading the
report members of this committee will
will all be aware that the council
doesn't have a site allocated for
travelers and this does leave us the
district open to speculative planning
applications for traveler sites it's in
a similar vain to not having an adopted
local plan for the settled
Community the current government policy
makes it clear that the green belt
should be protected and the planning
policy for travelers 2015 clearly states
the planning on green belt is
inappropriate and will cause harm and
acknowledges the need to respect the
interests of the settled community in
fact it states for planning authorities
to have due regard to the protection of
local imunity and local
environment policy e in that traveler
policy traveler sites in Green Belt
inappropriate development is harmful to
the green belt and should not be
approved except in very special
circumstances traveler sites temporary
or permanent in the green belt are
inappropriate development subject to the
best interest of the child personal
circumstances and unmet need are
unlikely to clearly outweigh harm to the
green belt and any other harm so as to
establish very special
circumstances National policy is not to
Grant permission because the local plan
g&t site allocation GT1 has not been
brought forward otherwise every piece of
green belt in Rochford regardless of
this particular circumstances would be
Su susceptible to traveler site
proposals policy states that any sites
must be appropriate and I would argue
that this site is not appropriate
especially given the proximity to the
settled Community prominence on the road
and the
access on page 2.72 there's narrative
around the suitability of the highway I
would ask you members to ask officers if
they confirm that this narrative has
been given by ECC or if this is their
own narrative each case of planning
should be assessed against policy and on
its own facts while comparisons can be
drawn each case is unique the planning
officers detailed other decisions that
support planning of course each of these
cases can be distinguished on their
facts equally there are other cases
where permission has been refused both
by planning and on appeal for example a
case turned down at appeal at land
adjacent to kezic Road and windir
Road this case demonstrated the clear
balance to be taken considering harm to
the green belt decision should not be
made on the basis that a refusal may go
to appeal this is not fair on residents
and it makes a mockery of the planning
system if an application is refused it
is important that all reasons for
refusal are clearly stated so that the
appeals
process may consider each of these
equally if permission is granted all the
reasons should be set out so that
residents can decide if they wish to
challenge residents are rightfully
concerned that the applicant has not
provided details of their occupation I
understand this has been discussed
earlier and it is not a
necessity residents have spoken to me
and they have asked about putting
conditional additional conditions in
place thank you chairman a condition and
a condition that there be no further
development rights on the
land no commercial plant or Machinery to
be stored on the site no commercial
activity be carried out from the
site and that the applicant cannot store
or deliver H deliver building or other
materials that will be used in their
occupation for work purposes on the site
our residents need to be assured that
this Council will Monitor and force and
enforce conditions and that conditions
are sufficient to provide as much Poss
protection as possible to the green belt
and Immunity thank you
members thank
[Applause]
you would any of the other visiting
members like to speak on this
application no okay okay so I will in
that case then open up to members of the
committee uh the we Ward Members
First Council Stanley I believe you're
award member would you like to
speak yes thank you chairman um first of
all I'm going to start this off by
saying that everyone has a place in the
community however on page
6.13
2.40 and onwards paragraph 13 of the
npps sets out these conditions a to
promote peaceful and integrated
coexistence between the site and the
local
community it also indicates that
children can attend school on a regular
basis but as these are Roman Egyptians
there is only six weeks that they can't
attend school as it's a school holidays
and no other that there are small
holidays in between but those are
they're going to be disruptive to these
children how would this pressure on the
local
infrastructure and services there will
be pressure on
those and on the
highway the stable Block in itself is
unlawful as we know so we are trying to
make it
lawful it's been unlawful for some
considerable time and nothing our
enforcement hasn't done uh due diligence
on that I don't
believe the size of the day room
although we know it's the stable block I
don't believe that one toilet is going
to be sufficient for two families in
fact it would probably be hygienic in
that in that
instance um a family of five yes that's
okay because it's maybe it's the whole
family of a five but there's more than
five on on this
site in um relation to the green belt
considerations and I'll bring you to
section 10 and 12 of this green
belt um the latest version of the
national ping policy
framework was revised in September 2023
like earlier Visions it emphasizes the
purpose of the planning system to be to
contribute to the achievement of
sustainable development through three
overarching objectives economic social
and
environmental it makes it plain that
planning policies and decision should
play an active role in guiding
development toward Sustainable
Solutions
these Sustainable Solutions should be
working with the
community of which I don't believe they
are and both policies gb1 and gb2 of the
core strategy seek to direct development
away from the Green Belt as far as
practical and prioritize the protection
of the green belt based on how well the
land helps to achieve the purpose of the
green belt
furthermore in our local development PR
framework development management plan on
page 46
3.45 residential conversion of existing
Agricultural and Rural buildings is not
considered appropriate in the green belt
or The Wider Countryside because it will
undermine the council's Strategic
approach to residential development and
over margin
sustainability objectives as detailed in
the core strategy further to this the
pertinent to the matter of employment
opportunities in the green belt and
wider Countryside business uses uses in
the Green Belt have potential to support
Economic Development and unemployment in
rural areas whereas residential
conversion does
not so all in all it's very much
is is it
helpful to the community minute
left one minute yeah is it helpful to
the community we have to look at that
and how the community integrates or
whether they integrate with the
community is it is it healthy for the
children to have these immunities that
on the
S and whether or not there is room for
them the children in school and other
places I suggest that the committee
needs to look at this very carefully
thank
you thank you cancel standy any other
members wishing to speak on this uh
councelor Wilson I believe you
first um thank you chairman the um a
similar situation arose on hullbridge
road um where there was occupancy um
from a a traveler family and it was one
of the conditions was specifically
um for that family and dependence and I
think that was to um protect the site
from continuous occupation from
different families and my question to
the officer is that a reasonable
condition um in this circumstance
picking up on councilor James newport's
Point um again is it a reasonable
condition to put onto the um site no
further development on the site um the
um question about um building material
materials and that would that need to be
very specific about what what we would
say can and can't be stored there um so
I'm thinking perhaps you might have um
material stored overnight for a job the
next day um and then finally restricting
commercial activity again that how would
that be um phrased as condition thank
you
chairman thank you councelor Wilson
councelor Ward thank you chairman um
I I just like to to go over the ppts
which is planning policy for traveler
sites just a couple of the things in
item three on that particular item uh
the government's overarching aim is to
ensure fair and equal treatment for
travelers in a way that facilitates the
traditional and nomadic way of life of
Travelers and I highlight this next part
while respecting the interests of the
settled community so we we have a very
important balance and it goes on on
point H it says to increase the number
of traveler sites in appropriate
locations and I think that's another
very very important point to take on
board is the site
appropriate I in the same ppts from item
four to reduce tensions between settled
and traveler communities in plan making
and planning decisions this is all from
the ppts this is what the planning
policy travel assign policy is about and
going on to K for local planning
authorities to have due regard to the
protection of local immunity and local
environment again this is another
balancing act that we've got to take
into consideration in weighing up what
we consider is the right waiting for
consideration um again I'm very pleased
uh I mean in the in the document item
seven on 21.8 again is emphasized uh
with regard to National planning policy
for traveler sites and also the
mppf again emphasizes as everyone has
been saying traveler sites temporary or
permanent in the green belt to be
inappropriate development in addition
the document states that subject to the
best interest of the child personal
circumstances and unmet need are
unlikely to outweigh the harm to the
green belt so as to establish very
special
circumstances now we have been privy to
confidential uh information which we
can't go
into um but I would like to go on to a
point that Council James Newport made
which I thought was very interesting uh
on 2.72 if I can draw members attention
to it there's an interesting point which
has been stated by our officers uh and
that's on the third line the I just like
just read the whole thing the
applications site would be accessed via
trenders Avenue which is a private road
the site itself would be accessed via
existing vehicle vehicle access point
now coming up interesting point whilst
the visibility spay of this vehicle
access point would not be ideal that's a
very unusual statement it's like uh we
had the problems over severe what is
ideal what is severe I think this needs
to be tested I know that Junction very
well and I know it to be extremely
dangerous it is a dangerous Junction and
I think it's totally unsuitable as far
as I am concerned and that needs to be
tested and if it hasn't been it really
does need to be as far as that's
concerned
um I do feel as well just going on to
the mppf uh protecting green belt and I
must come back to this again uh 147 of
the planning policy on under number 13
policy 13 uh inappropriate development
by definition harmful to the green belt
and should not be approved except in
very special circumstances that's the
balancing we have to consider and going
on to 148 when considering any planning
application local planning authorities
should ensure that substantial weight is
given to any harm to the green Bel very
special circumstances will not exist
unless the potential harm to the green
belt by reason of inappropriateness
thank you and any other harm resulting
from The Proposal is clearly outweighed
by other considerations now what is any
other harm well the national planning
policy guidance really does sum this up
and it looks at openness and this is a
very very important Point openness is
capable of having both spatial and
visual aspects in other words the visual
impact of The Proposal may be relevant
as could its volume the duration of the
development and its remedi ability
taking into account any provisions to
return land to its original state or to
an equivalent or improved state of
openness and the degree of activity
likely to be generated such as traffic
generation in my considered opinion the
proposed development would have a
detrimental impact on both the spatial
and visual aspect
of openness and I do not concur with the
officer's
recommendation thank
you okay any other members wishing to
speak on this
item no
okay okay the recommendation is to
approve the application subject to the
conditions set out on page oh sorry on I
do apologize Katie you have a number of
questions that were put to you
there I'll um go in reverse order so
paragraph 2.72 mentions the access or um
access point and says that that's not
ideal that's in relation to the
vehicular access to the site not onto
Roth Lane um so that hope that clarifies
what that's in reference to in terms of
it not being ideal it as you can see if
I
use the thing when you're coming out of
the site you would slightly be obscured
by this current boundary obviously we
are aiming to improve that boundary
treatment by one of the conditions
officers have recommended um however as
in the report due to the condition and
uh status of the road vehicles would be
traveling at such a slow speed that that
it's not considered dangerous and we
have consulted ESS County Council
Highway Authority and they've also
raised no objection
um
[Music]
the there was a question about um
whether a personal um condition could be
put on that is on the application at
present that's conditioned to um in
terms of other conditions relating to no
further development the storage of
building materials and the commercial
activity what we have to be mindful of
is what the current proposal is for um
it's for to two mobile homes and two
touring Caravans and there is a
condition which restricts it to that
number of Caravans on the site so you
wouldn't be able to create any
additional um gypsy or traveler pitches
on the site without applying for
permission to for to the council um
there
is I think we can reasonably expect that
the applicant because of their
occupation in the Labor Field that they
may have uh vehicle
or um I guess operative equipment that
could reasonably be stored on the site
the same as any member of the settled
community may also who works in the
Labor Field bring those sorts of
vehicles um back and leave them on their
driveway during the evening as I've said
there is no uh proposal at the moment to
utilize the site for commercial activity
and so that's not what we're considering
however um JS has advised that in other
instances there has been a condition put
on an application which has uh
restricted commercial activity from the
site so if you are not content with our
view on that then I'm sure JS can direct
to the reason of vality behind
that John would you like to take that
one up please thank you well I was going
to say something else actually but I
will I will come to that point um I just
wanted to say something about the ppts
which is for those you don't know I mean
you're all quite familiar with it
planning policy for traveler sites which
is the government policy on Gypsy and
traveler sites it's it's part of the
nppf in
effect um it's important to understand
when reading this document that there
are
two important
sections first plan
making which is POL which is paragraphs
8 to
21 and following that decision taking
which is paragraphs
22 to 20 to
now a number of members have referred to
paragraph
13 um which sets out a number of
aspirations if you like and whilst they
are relevant to decision making they are
primarily aimed at plan making they
appear in that part of the
ppts now those attributes at paragraph
13 for example promote peaceful
integrated
coexistence promote in collaboration
with commissions of Health Access to
appropriate Health that children can
attend school and so on that is what the
local Authority has to do when making
plans which means identifying sites so
that if an application comes forward
there will be a site in the plan now as
you all are aware there haven't been
identified in this case in this burrow a
fiveyear supply of sites which means
that the second part of the ppts is
therefore more relevant that part
directed at decision taking and if you
look at paragraph 24 that's where we see
and this is why the officers have
emphasized this in the report
local planning authorities should
consider the following issues when
considering planning applications a the
existing level of local provision and
need for sites and that's why the
officer has correctly pointed out that
there isn't a fiveyear supply nor any
allocated sites B the availability or
lack of alternative accommodation for
the appellants applicants and and you've
been the members have been addressed on
that in private and see other personal
circumstance es of the
applicant and then over the page the
locally specific
criteria um in any policy now again
there isn't a locally specific criteria
policy in existence so it's for that
reason that the officers have focused as
they have in their recommendation on the
absence of a 5year supply the lack of
alternative accommodation and the
personal circumstances of the applicant
so I think that's that's a useful um I
hope way of looking at ppts and sorry
your question was about a potential
condition to restrict commercial use
yeah
it's it's it's not uncommon in my
experience that if if members are
concerned about businesses being
operated from the site uh that they
might apply condition I'm not aware
though in this case that that is
proposed by the applicants so obviously
would need to be uh considered in the
context of
that thank you
Char right um in that case then in the
absence of any
further uh debate on that um oh so
Council FY thank you chairman can I
recommend me that we put the condition
on commercial on this just in case it
goes to appe any got
consideration okay so your motion is if
you could just put
the as chares didn't elaborate on what
the condition to limit commercial
activity on the site would be but I
think we should put some sort of
limitation on the commercial activity
that might go on on the site in the
future if this does go to appeal I don't
if we can do that or not because it was
alluded to by the
officer my feeling on that is that we
need to put some sort of level on that I
believe um sorry I was just going to say
that if you were recommending the
application for approval we could put
the condition on as part of that motion
but if the recommend the sorry movement
is for refusal we would have to consider
any conditions at an appeal stage we
wouldn't be a to oppose that now isn't
it already for approval there not
nothing's coming the motion hasn't been
moved yet though all right
okay okay so in that case then uh the
recommendation is to approve the
application subject to the conditions
set out on pages 7.1 to 7.4 of the
report and subject to the amended
conditions set out on pages five to
seven of the addendum do I have a second
sorry as it's for approval can we put
that condition on
please I need a seconder first please do
I have a seconder I have second thank
you Council so those in favor
[Music]
of so let me clarify this Council are
you actually seconding or are you asking
a question about the well we need to
Second it to we've already second it to
discuss it now you want to Second the
approval and the officer said you can
only put the addition the condition on
if it's set for approval so I'd like the
condition put on about limiting
commercial okay so now you need to
clarify your condition then I don't know
because Charles didn't elaborate what
the condition was Charles can you please
elaborate what the condition
was I don't think it's for jles to
actually uh make the the condition you
can ask for his advice ask his advice
please I'm I'm sure if
um you move to impose a condition
restricting um commercial
activity and that's accepted and the
committee goes on then to recommend
approval I'm sure we could well the
officers could um over the next day or
two come up with a suitable form of
words I mean there are in fact a number
of sort of precedents I don't have them
to hand but simply restrict effectively
seek to restrict the use of the site for
any kind of commercial activity
um I I stress again though it's not from
my understanding of what's proposed that
that there would be any um commercial
activity at the sites is that is that
correct that's
correct okay um I don't you know what to
say with that but I'm quite happy if
they does go for approval that the
officers come up with some wording on
that if if that's okay
okay anyone
else no okay right there is a make a
recommendation for
approval and
uh
okay I'm being advised that um if there
is a uh a condition that is to be put on
approval then we do need the committee's
approval
so in that case
[Music]
um I I am uh going to defer to Giles
here for a bit of advice but it the sort
of information I I thought I heard was
that this can be added afterwards which
is a little bit against what I've always
learned as being the part of the
committee's involvement well I think my
advice is yes certainly the committee
needs to decide that it wants to impose
a condition restrict in commercial
use probably that could be done by
um forming amending the resolution as it
were so rather than just approve the the
recommendation in the office's report
makes make clear that there is to be
added a further condition restricting
commercial use but the actual wording of
it um I don't think we could I don't
think it'd be a problem in drafting
something okay so my then is that we
need to actually have a motion on the
table so back to you councilor FD if you
could give us the wording of the motion
put a motion on the table
to um reference to proper wording to put
a restriction on Commercial activities
at the
site do we have that seconded please
councilor
Wilson all those in favor of that uh
motion please indicate
I'm now being advised that I need to
have your agreement just to put that
additional condition on
so okay we'll get there in the
end okay so uh sorry sorry can I have a
show of hands for agreement on that
please
okay thank you those
against against none against any
abstentions okay that is carried we have
seven for none against and six
abstentions so now we go to the
substantial recommendation which I shall
read again the recommendation is to
approve the application subject to the
conditions set out on pages 7.1 to 7.4
of the report and subject to the amended
conditions set out on pages 5 to 7 of
the
addendum so can I have a seconder
please councel refd thank
you and or can I have an indication for
those in favor
those in favor of the uh the
recommendation the officer's
recommendation okay the additional
condition with the additional
condition okay a shove hands yeah just
two okay those
against
thank you members uh
[Music]
abstentions okay so that application is
refused the numbers are no the approval
the approval is L is lost so we need so
that is uh two for 10 against and one
abstention so I need someone now to
propose reasons why we should refuse
this councelor
Ward thank you very much
chairman um well we've we've had quite a
long conversation in regards to this but
I will give the basis of for
refusal
um it's inappropriateness of development
in the green
belt a negative relationship to the
grouping of houses close by the
unsatisfactory access for Caravan
traffic and the harmful impact on local
character and amenity and I would like
to add if I may chairman to this um if
this does go to appeal when the council
receives notification from the planning
inspectorate we would like officers to
respond that we would like an informal
Hearing in the mode of appeal the reason
being so that members and residents can
support the council in its reasons for
refusal can we do do I have a second
out Council
[Music]
standing okay uh would you like to read
the recommendation can I just make an
amendment to that motion uh we I think
we we need
to so members we we we we have a motion
removed by Council award which has been
seconded by councelor Stanley that the
application be refused and I think the
grounds are uh broadly around in
inappropriate development in the green
belt um and negative grouping of hous
nearby um inadequate access for uh for
Caravans and for detrimental impact on
residential
amusing are you in agreement with that
counc I'll just read I'll read that back
if if I may just to clarify for
ease um is the basis of
inappropriateness of development in the
green
belt a negative relationship to the
grouping of Housing close
by the
unsatisfactory access for Caravan
traffic and the harmful impact on local
character and Immunity and have you
taken note
of the appeal item as well okay can I
read that for clarity if this does go to
appeal Council can I just ask um if that
is admissible ail uh within the reasons
for
refusal is is what are those
reasons I I'll come to the reasons in a
minute um in the appeal item that
Council W is trying to the way the way
it works is um
if this is
appealed pins will offer both parties
either the appellant and the council uh
the opportunity to indicate which means
of appeal either written reps a formal
hearing or most formal of all a public
inquiry um the public actually uh has
most access to a public inquiry they can
attend hearings as well but they have
less opportunity to to take part so if
your concern is that you want members to
be present or to take part I would
suggest that the public inquiry would
probably be the best forum for that uh
but we don't I it's not something which
needs to be decided now we will be asked
in due course to give an indication of
how the council wishes for this to be
dealt so my understanding of that then
is that is a decision which he's you
further down the line I shall I say
something about the reasons now yes
please do okay
well the important thing is that when a
committee refuses permission it has to
do so for planning reasons you know that
and what you what youve indicated are
planning reasons so they they can't be
faulted in that sense it seems to me and
let's just let's just go through them
first reason inappropriate development
in the green
belt well we know that so what you're
saying really is not outweighed by very
special
circumstances okay so that's the first
reason inappropriate Green Belt not
outweighed
by so that vscs exist the
second point the negative relationship
to houses
nearby is this a
is this a townscape point are you
talking about the the appearance the the
relationship in the character and
appearance if you like of what is
proposed as against the existing
houses it's it's
basically it is relevant to the ACT ual
local vicinity and the imunity in the
area okay well they're different things
so if you're
saying the appearance of the Caravans is
detrimental no no okay it's it's an
immunity point so your your your your
point is that the proposed development
will have an adverse impact on the
immunity of existing resid Residential
[Music]
Properties on residential amenity of
existing
properties the second sorry the third
Point inadequate
access it's a highways point you you're
saying essentially that it's it's not
satisfactory in Highway terms
and is is dangerous
or
questionable all
right and then the final point you said
um local character and
Immunity uh now as I say there different
things we we've dealt with immunity with
the second reason so is the fourth
reason it's
about is that about something else is
that about character and appearance of
what is proposed is that what you're
getting
[Music]
at all right
well I think I understand
the gist of those four reasons and the
officers will be able to in the next few
days articulate them they have to have
reference of course to relevant policies
I'll just remind you uh what the uh DMO
says reasons to be given when permission
is refused must be stated clearly and
precisely
before specify all policies and
proposals and development plan which are
relevant to the
decision so that's what the officers
will be able to do on on the basis of
this instruct this instruction will be
able to articulate those four reasons uh
in a in a correct way okay thank you
Charles I am aware now that uh um we
need to extend the meeting uh members we
now have eight minutes left in which we
can legally proceed therefore I we'll
move a motion without notice in line
with committee procedure rule 9 N to
extend this meeting Beyond two and a
half hours for as long as necessary to
complete the remaining business can I
have a second that please councilor
laurman thank you or those in favor
please raise your
hand got okay that is passed we have
eight in favor of that so we will
continue with the meeting now I believe
that that has has now
completed counc San you want to say
something yes I I want I did ask if I
could ex extend that reason
for
refusal sorry councel
St advice that's right you got ear both
sides um yes um I want you to emphasize
a couple of items to extend that reason
for
refusal I think we have we haven't
mentioned we haven't mentioned the n
ppts on the paragraph 13 of the
condition that promotes peaceful and
coexistence with the residents that are
already there we didn't we haven't
spoken about that and I do believe that
that is a CR criteria that we need to
put in if councilor Ward will agree with
that can we have advice on that please J
so what do you mean what are you
saying what what do you mean sorry what
do you mean well uh paragraph 13 yeah of
the mpps ppts yeah says the co existence
with the with the residential
Community yeah which so you you want to
add a reason
and that is a reason
why you're you're you're suggesting that
an additional reason
is this proposal would
fail to promote peaceful and integrated
coexistence between cor and Community
cor yes
correct if Council Ward will accept that
on that proposal
counc i' accept it
I believe Katie wants to uh come
back Sor Phil oh sorry Phil got well
chair thank you um I would just my
advice is I would caution against adding
reasons for refusal um it's if if you'll
pardon the phrase I think it's about
quality rather than quantity I think
it's important to focus on the planning
reasons why you think it's um relevant
to refuse the application which Council
of orders set out I would actually and
and of course this is members decision I
would caution against the highways
aspect of reason for refusal on the
basis we don't have an objection from
the highway Authority who are the
highway Authority and therefore the
experts on this point so I would um I
would suggest that members focus it on
planning reasons that are that are not
Highway related but in terms councilor
Stanley of your question
there GES has already responded in the
debate to say that the ppts paragraphs
including paragraph 13 refer to plan
making that's when the council is
writing a local plan producing a local
plan to set out where Gypsy and traveler
s should be among other things um so
that would be my suggestion that that
isn't necessarily relevant and it is
very close I would suggest at Council
Awards Point around amenity and perhaps
that should be where the focus
is chair if I'm might the the road in
question is a private road and and the
highway Authority have no Authority in
that road whatsoever and also if we are
making or setting out conditions where
we've written in at the n p pbts then we
should uphold those conditions
especially with the community as it
stands so I I would request that that
stays in please my opinion for what it's
worth is that I think that we should
stick with what council W has proposed
um and just move on um now I'm
uh councel Ward are you happy with uh
sticking with your original
objections I believe that conditions
need to be as
uncomplicated as possible and they need
to be based strictly on planning law so
I am content that with j is advocacy
that I have arrived at the
correct
conditions re reasons re re I think one
of the things that that was being asked
of me to ask you is that following the
advice from Phil drain are you confident
that you want to keep in the highways
issue uh having received the advice from
Phil uh I think we can drop that
one
keep in it's your decision keep in
because on the
highways again going back to that we
were looking if I may
say unsatisfactory access for Caravan
traffic I want that left in yeah no no
change to anything I've done okay well
uh Phil's advice is noted um but uh okay
so those conditions for refusal then
um Okay so we've heard the conditions I
don't think we need them repeated
again there four I believe it's four
conditions in the end for four reasons I
should say so we're keeping highways we
taking out the last one which counil
suggested
okay um going on the advice that we've
had from from our legal side I think
that makes sense but okay so now uh we
need um to vote on that please
so okay are you okay with what we've
heard or do you need it
repeated they can these the reasons for
refusal before we vote are okay let me
make it easy then are you happy to
proceed without rereading the re reasons
for refusal yes okay thank you so in
that case then those in favor of the
reasons for refusal please
indicate thank you members those
against and
exensions okay so the vote is 11 for
none against two abstentions so the
reasons for refusal are
accepted application is
refused okay so moving on now
to um I'm being advised that uh members
might need a five minute Comfort break
and this one would be five minutes
um do do members want that and I'll keep
it very strictly to five minutes do you
want it yes yes okay five minutes be
back in 5 minutes
please sorry 5
okay
members if I can reconvene please
members okay
now
on okay okay everybody let's uh call the
meeting to order again we're on agenda
item eight land wests side Junction of
Magnolia Road and Lincoln Ro Rochford uh
can I have quiet please thank you uh
members there is additional information
relating to this application set out in
the addendum Katie Fowler will present
the officer's
report thank you Katie thank you
chairman the application site is located
on the corner of Magnolia Road and
Lincoln Road the site is formed of a
triangular plle of land and measures an
area of some 0.8 hectar so we can see
that by this red line which extends
around the site here
Magnolia Road and Lincoln Road are
private single track roads and the site
is AD joined to the north by dor Lodge
which is located Here Wayside Lodge to
the West which is here and then is also
opposite to the Glenn or the shin
friendly
cery the site is largely unoccupied with
the exception of a couple of dilapidated
buildings I'll just take members through
some site photos so we can see here the
grazing pad well the grazing land that
exists at the moment and you can see two
horses just in the background of that
photo you can also see how the boundary
treatments of the substantial trees and
hedge
row um this photo just shows the
dilapidated buildings which are on site
at present so you can see this likely
once formed an old stable block and then
some sort of agricultural equestrian
building as
well we can also see the boundary
treatments and the current state of the
site so so we have some dense trees
around the middle and then we also have
some dense trees and hedge rows along
the Northwest boundary and then also the
eastern boundary here in the foreground
of the sorry background of the photo
just here you can see the roof of dor
Lodge so this photo just shows the site
access from uh on Lincoln Road into the
site and we have the gate and some
Paddock fencing marking
that this photo is looking upwards on
Lincoln Road and so you can see the
dense vegetation which demarcates the
boundaries here we are looking Southward
on uh Lincoln Road towards Magnolia Road
in the
background and then here we are looking
uh westwards on Magnolia road so behind
this vegetation here we have the
application site and then behind this
vegetation is the railway
[Music]
line plan of commission is sought for
the change of use of land for the
stationing of two pitches for two Roman
EG Gypsy families each pitch would
include one mobile home one touring
Caravan and one day room the change of
uses also sought to allow for the
keeping of horses on the land the
application site is located within the
greenber where restrictive policies
apply the national planning policy for
traveler sites sets out that traveler
sites in the green bell are
inappropriate development which is
harmful by definition in addition The
Proposal would have an impact on the
openness of the green belt in terms of
the proposal's contribution towards the
purpose of green belt land the
development would constitute Urban spra
encroachment The Proposal would
therefore be considered to have a
greater impact on openness and would
fail to meet the aims and purposes of
allocating land within the Green Boat
any harm to the green boat is attributed
substantial weight which must be clearly
outweighed by very special
circumstances the very special
circumstances of the application have
been set out within the officer report
these include the existing lack of local
provision the lack of alternative
accommodation and the personal
circumstances of the applicant in
particular the best interests of the
child are a primary consideration in
this application as the site would
accommodate children under 16 and where
permission refused the families would be
forced to live on the side of the road
although not necessarily a determinative
issue no other consideration must be
considered to be more important or given
them more weight the best interest of
the child must be at the Forefront of
decision makers Minds when they're
exercising all planning judgments
involved in this case is considered that
there are a number of matters which are
considered to weigh significantly in
favor of the application and this
conclusion would be consistent with the
outcome of the recent appeal decisions
the artive weight of these other
considerations are considered to clearly
outweigh the substantial harm in the
green belt whilst the devel would not be
typical for the character of Magnolia
Road or Lincoln Road The Proposal must
not be discriminated against against
because the homes of the ethnic group do
not let Li those of the settled
communities conditions have been imposed
regarding the Landscaping on site with
the intention of ensuring in integration
of the development within the street
scene is considered that there would be
sufficient separation with nearby
Residential Properties so that post
development would not have an
overbearing oversharing or overlooking
impact that would be unreasonable the
material considerations pertaining to
the impact on residential Mente have
been laid out within the officer report
and found to be acceptable the proposed
development is considered to provide
sufficient access and parking although
no specific details of the file trainers
have been submitted a condition has been
recommended requiring these details it
is highlighted that the site is within
an area at risk of surface water
flooding as such a condition has been
recommended to be imposed requiring a
surface water drainage scheme be
agreed with the local planning
Authority imposing such a good condition
is not unusual for a site that embodies
characteristics such as a large extent
of Green Field there are a number of
trees and hedges around the perim of the
application site some of the proposal
for some of the proposed hard standing
would likely be within the root
protection area of a number of these
trees as such a condition has been
recommended requiring an aricultural
impact assessment be
submitted an ecological appraisal was
submitted with the application which
highlighted that the site Encompass
potential habitats for a number of
protecting species subject to the
implementation of the recommended
mitigation and safeguarding measures out
lied in this appraisal is considered
that no significant harm to any habitats
or foral species of Interest would occur
while some comments have been received
regarding extend in the access and the
removal of trees to facilitate this no
breach of planning control has occurred
the trees are not protected at present
and any ecological harm would be covered
by the environmental act not planning
legislation in making this decision
membership be mindful of the neighbor
joining the site at DOR Lodge who shares
protected characteristics as defining
the equalities act views have been
expressed which indicate that the
proposed development would have a
detrimental impact upon this neighbor in
regards to a Visual and noise impact n
EX exercising the Public Service of
quality Duty careful consideration has
been given to the feelings and concerns
expressed in the assessment of the
impact upon the person of protected
characteristics legal advice has been
taken in terms of the weight that could
be reasonably attached to this balanced
against the other material
considerations including the best
interest of the child of the applicants
the application is recommended for
approval chairman subject to the
conditions set out within the USA report
and the
addendums thank you
k there are three public speakers for
this item uh the first speaker is
councelor May speaking on behalf of hul
Parish Council if you would like to come
to the mic please you will have five
minutes and I will let you know when you
have a minute left thank
you right it
goes okay item one on our submission the
site is within the green belt IDC has
previously refused planning permission
applications at the site due to its
Green Belt status when the land was
auctioned in
2021 RDC stated that planning permission
would not be permitted the legal pack
stated is not lawful to undertake
residential or commercial development
and there's no Prospect of planning
permission for residential or commercial
development being granted
HPC firmly believed that there has been
no material changes which would alter
rdc's stated
view item two policy e traveler sites in
the green belt inappropriate development
is harmful to the green belt and should
not be approved except in exceptional
special exceptional circumstances
traveler sites temporary or permanent in
the green belt are an an improvement
development the planning statement with
the application States the proposed
application will demonstrate that there
would at worst be limited or other harm
to the character and appearance of the
area HPC believes that in no there is no
evidence has been provided with the
application that are very special
circumstances exist that would overwrite
the harbon to the green
belt three um Essex
highways HBC noted that e the highways
have now given no objection response to
the application the response talks about
the width of the bellmouth junction of
rectory Road into the publicly
maintained Highway where rectory road
then transitions into Magnolia Road this
location is near the entrance to
Magnolia Park and nature reserve and is
not the junction that HPC and residents
are concerned about the junction of
Magnolia Road and Lincoln Road a private
road is a very narrow with an entrance
to thec location site being located a
few meters inside Lincoln Road when
exiting from Lincoln Road into Magnolia
road which itself is a narrow road the
visibility in each direction is limited
HPC further notes that their response is
partially based on collision data
records for the past five years HPC
believes that using Collision data alone
does not give the true picture regarding
Road Safety near the application site as
not all instance near misses Etc would
be reported or including in the
Collision data HBC and many local
residents have concerns about the safety
to people during the extra traffic
movements asso associated with Caravans
and the visitors moving in and out of
the site into the narrow and private
road there is a scout hon day Nursery at
this Junction where parents drop off
weight and maneuver around this narrow
Junction further there is no Pavements
and minimal Street Li in this location
which which would exacerbate safety
concerns particularly for pedestrians
who use the
road trees and
hedges the applicants provideed a no
response to the question that there are
trees or Hedges on the land adjacent to
proposed development that could affect
the local landscape character HPC
manages the designated Magnolia nature
res Park and nature reserve which
provides a quiet and tranquil habitat
for many species of reptiles mammals and
birds including rare and protected
species hedge RS surrounding the
application site which provide Havens
for nutes and nesting Birds HPC welcomes
the amendments to condition nine
retaining Landscaping but still request
a full tree survey is undertaken before
before a decision is
made assessment of flood risk the
application applicants provided a no
response to the question is the site RIS
minute left the site floods severely in
the winter months and service water runs
from ashington Heights Down Lincoln Road
and Durham Road which is no drainage
into Magnolia Road East Essex County
Council categorizes the area as a high
risk of
flooding HPC welcomes the additional
recommendation in regard of permeable
materials and construction method
however HBC is still concerned regarding
the welfare of the horses which would be
capturing the area on the Magnolia Road
boundary the area most accessible to
access proport of
flooding planning use keeping horses
there does not be any error in the plans
for stabling the horses HPC questions
why this matter has been omitted in the
application details and plans when
keeping the horses is set out as a key
aspect of the
application waste storage and collection
the applic the ation form States and no
response to the Plans Incorporated areas
to
waste HBC believes that the issue of
waste needs to be addressed in detail as
the key issue of health and
safety biodiversity and geological
conservation there are numerous rare and
projected species in the Nature Reserve
including Great Crested NES Badgers and
mon Jack gear dear okay hedgehogs and
numerous Birds I think we've heard that
point you are actually over time now so
if you could just bring that to a close
thank you okay thank you very
much thank you councelor mate I did
actually let run over so um I hope
you understand that we do have a timing
issue here um second speaker is Mr Green
who is speaking on behalf of the
applicants Mr Green please take your
place at the microphone as you know you
have five minutes and I will again let
you know when we come to a minute the
end thank you chair committee
um
okay to reiterate uh this application is
for the Mixed use of the keeping of
horses and stationing of Caravans
residential use and the laying of hard
standing and erection of day room anill
to that use in effect two Gypsy pit
it is accepted that development in the
green belt is inappropriate um but once
again the council officers have
recommended approval and showing that
Council officers at least have
understood that there are very special
circumstances that outweigh this um once
again I need to remind you that um there
is a requirement for at least 10 uh
pitches in the area and uh this is
likely to be an
underestimate our client and his family
are accepted as having Gypsy status and
it is accepted by the council that their
present living arrangements involve
doubling up with other members of the
extended
family so as as again noted in your
report it's not for the applicant to
establish whether they are there are
available sites but for the
council the council cannot demonstrate a
five-year land supply of deliver or
Gypsy sites and this coupled with the
lack of formal policy regarding windfall
sites such as this one constitutes a
failure of policy that also counts
heavily in favor of the
application I may also say the reason I
keep repeating this is so that there is
no let out at appeal that you were
told this application therefore
demonstrates more than one very special
circumstance that is required to
outweigh the harm to the green
belt the two families involved are
related through their extended family
allowing this application will allow the
Conners to have a stable base for their
eight children that will allow them to
have an education that at present they
do not have access to in particular one
child will then be able to access a
special needs school that at present the
child is unable to do so lacking a
formal address the same child also has a
health issue that stable based will
assist the Gaskin children are also in a
local school and this will ensure they
continue to receive their education and
again one child has a learning
difficulty and this proximity to the
child's existing school will assist its
education you'll also note from your
report that the two m of the family have
mental health issues that a settled
environment will assist and another
child has a mental has a medical issue
that is treated in London and the site's
proximity to London will help in that
regard and once again I can tell you
that should you wish wish to go into
close session then you will have full
access to all of th all of that data as
before the site lies in Countryside that
is well screened on two sides by dense
vegetation the developed area is on the
Eastern side of the site where it is
surrounded by scrub the the proposed
plan shows that the further planting of
trees and hedges will be implemented
primarily along the entrance way along
further planting can be conditioned as
you will see from your site visit the
nearest occupied dwelling is 28 MERS
away to the north and as all structures
will be single story there will be no
overlooking the legal separation
distance for a two-story building that
is the neighbor's existing property is
14 M this is double the minimum
separation distance and 10 meters of
that distance is dense
vegetation and has and has been strongly
reiterated by the highways officer there
is considered to be no impact upon
highways a comprehensive ecological
survey was undertaken this year and it
confirms that no statutary or
non-statutory designations are present
within the site it recommended some
ecological enhancements be implemented
and these are in the conditions and are
willing to be
accepted the site is close to bridleways
and as the application is also for the
keeping of horses this will have
significant safety and Welfare benefits
the keeping of horses off the road
Network at the previous committee the
issue of surface water flooding was
raised upon Consulting the flood risk
Maps there is no risk of flooding from
Rivers the southern part of the site is
vulnerable to some surface water
flooding but crucially the area where
the Caravans are proposed to sit is not
at risk the recommendation comes with 19
condition no client is happy to comply
with them and I'd also like to point out
to you that if you read the rules
regarding the Ombudsman it is perfectly
acceptable for a planning committee to
consider the cost of potential appeals
uh and when coming to your decisions so
on this basis I urge you to um approve
the application thank
you thank you Mr
Green our third speaker is M Bain who is
objecting to the application Miss Bain
please take your place at the microphone
you'll have five minutes to speak and I
will let you know when you get to one
minute uh left thank
you for allowing me to the opportunity
to speak good evening my name is key
Spain I live with my three children in
dor Lodge which borders the development
site I find it unacceptable that my
children haven't been afforded the same
rights as the applicant's children
I'm being forced to publicly share my
family's medical histories here this
evening unlike the applicants who shared
their privately with your
officer I fully appreciate that the
applicant wants to support their
children so do I I've been fighting for
my child's rights all of his life my son
K has cereal posy caused by medical
negligence at Birth the NHS failed him
Kai's disability has a substantial and
long-term adverse effect on his ability
to carry out normally normal daytoday
activities my daughter Maisy has
leukemia and my daughter Eden is a young
carer for her siblings deputies have
been appointed for Kai by the court of
protection this is a superior court of
record created under the mental capacity
act
2005 the deputies are responsible for
all decisions about property finances
personal welfare as Kai lacks the mental
capacity to make them for himself had
this site already been established when
viewing direct Lodge's potential the
property would have been deemed
unsuitable for Kai's
Rehabilitation Kai suffers daily from
joint pain muscle pain he has very
little balance and his right side is
very
weak he is verbal but struggles with
social social communication Kai gets
confused and anxious he is extremely
self-conscious and suffers with
debilitating
anxiety Lincoln Road is a private road
it is rural in character and we have a
modest dwelling within a large garden
our home was chosen with agreement from
the NHS and deputies to provide Kai with
a quiet and tranquil place to live life
to his full
potential location was a crucial Factor
not just for Kai Maisy needs peace and
quiet to fight her awful disease plus we
need good transport links to London for
her regular hospital
treatment Kai benefit from this
wonderful natural environment he has the
freedom to continue his alternative
education in a safe place as ess6 County
counil failed
him it the officer's report only focuses
on the street scene point a page
8.14 it completely ignores that you must
ensure this traveler site promotes
peaceful and integrated coexistence with
the local
community counselors I know you've had
training on these issues this is a
material consideration that carries
significant weight we are the local
community my children will be impacted
forever when assessing in a rural area
you must ensure the traveler site does
not dominate the nearest settled
Community I.E us there are four of us in
the family home versus 12 children and
four adults it is going to dominate us
fact noise is a material consideration
you must consider the noise and
disturbance generated by this site Kai
due to his disabilities he particularly
sensitive to changes in his surroundings
excess noise and visual stimulus Kai is
overwhelmed by loud noises and large
numbers of people the physiological
effects will be weight loss panic
attacks and withdrawal from family and
Society the noise and activity generated
by the proposed use with 12 children and
four adults living meters away and
predominantly outdoor living will have
devastating cone consequences to him so
those members that kindly visited the
site please imagine the impact this site
would cause to Kai's life imagine the
noise levels with 12 CH 12 children and
the D rooms and Caravans in constant use
next to our property minute left our
tranquil lives will be
shattered significant loss of privacy
are also material considerations Kai has
a neuropsych ol ologist an occupational
therapist a physiotherapist and a case
manager to oversee all aspects of his
mental and physical health and wellbeing
Kai also has has a living support worker
which enables him to engage in daily
activities and to buffer any
environmental scenarios that are outside
the control of our house all therapy
takes place in our home and garden since
moving here K has improved and his panic
attacks have started to reduce he will
stop all outdoor activities which will
exacerbate his health conditions he will
regress this site will mean Kai will
lose his privacy please consider his
needs when making your decision in
conclusion on the grounds of noise
disturbance loss of privacy failure to
protect the green belt failing to
promote peaceful coexistence failing to
protect an area of
tranquility and most importantly failing
to protect my child's human rights I
respectfully request this application is
refused the NHS failed him Essex County
Council failed him I beg you rord
District councilors his councilors
please do not faou Kai thank you for
your
[Music]
[Applause]
time thank you Mr Bain and now I move on
to uh Members First of all we have Ward
members and I'm led to believe that uh
all the three Ward members wish to speak
on this um I'll invite them to speak in
order of seniority so uh counselor Mrs
Mason if you'd like to come to the
microphone first
please
thank you chair I hope you're not
referring to my
age I wouldn't
hear right thank you chair members good
evening this planning application
creates a dilemma for the committee as
you are being asked to compare two
different and competing needs in order
to resolve the
application the government has set
different criteria for members of The
Traveling Community with regards to
Green Belt development but still wants
any proposal to be appropriate with due
regard to the local
community the officer report reflects
this priority by stating that the
application should be considered for
approval due to the personal
circumstances of the applicant being
considered to outweigh the harm to the
green
belt whilst I acknowledge their stated
needs to relocate to our area there are
material planning reasons that can
override this need and I believe that
the committee should consider these
competing needs of the existing
residents and determine and that's all
existing residents and determine that on
balance this application should be
refused if firstly we look at the site
apart from its Green Belt status it is
also heavily prone to flooding which has
placed the proposed location of the
dwellings nearer to Doric Lodge although
the layout may be indicative the
sighting and activities of two large
families will naturally include outdoor
activities play and noise which will
impact on both the children NE
negatively the issue of water retention
on the site restricts the location and
inevitably this will impact on the
residence of dor
Lodge the reason that this relationship
with dor Lodge is fundamental to your
considerations is due to the unusual
situation of the residents there due to
a severe brain injury at Birth this
vulnerable young man is under the court
of protection which is charged with
looking after the needs of the most
vulnerable members of our
society those with the most extreme
needs have a professional Deputy
appointed by the courts as opposed to a
lay deputy and this young man sadly
falls into this category of being one of
the most vulnerable members of our
community as you have heard from his
mother and I can only say that that must
have been very distressing for her to
have to say that I understand that the
professional deputies chose Doric Lodge
for his home after extensive searches to
facil at his wellbeing in a quiet and
settled area to help him
rehabilitate you will have heard about
the negative impact this proposal
already has had on his well-being so I
will not repeat that
information the mppf provides that
inappropriate development would only be
considered very special
circumstances if it outweighs the harm
to both the green belt and the settled
Community any very special circumstances
here are outweighed by the harm to the
settled community and an extremely
vulnerable young man and the harm to the
green
belt in this case I strongly suggest
that the very special needs of the
settled Community as demonstrated to you
all outweighs the personal needs of The
Travelers wishing to relocate to this
area the harm to both the existing
community and the green belt location is
immeasurable please refuse this
application thank
you thank you councelor Mrs Mason and I
believe the next speaker will be
councelor Julie
Gooding as with everyone else I'll give
you five minutes and and when it gets to
the one minute I will let you
know thank you chairman and
members I am here to represent the
residents of hul westal you have all
seen the personal medical details
provided by his mother Miss Blain issued
by the Court deputies containing
doctor's reports on Kai also seen is the
high Court of protection deputies which
instructed the planning Consultants to
issue the letter containing key
considerations to be taken into account
which you have also
received dor Lodge was specifically
Chosen and agreed as a suitable zone of
Tranquility by a high court judge and
protection deputies given the importance
of the surroundings of Kai's home and
outdoor space in relation to his medical
needs par 123 mppf the noise policy have
the committee been provided with a
report showing how SE how severe the
impact of acoustic noise would create if
they were to be granted this
application living on the plot and the
adverse impact on Kai's quality of life
as per the equality act 2010 an
assessment is advis to measure the
acoustic noise generated by the proposed
development to enable members to make an
informed
decision and this all refers to par two3
of the mppf noise
policy page
8.13 par 2. 2330 of the development
report refers to the applicant child
with learning difficulties and requires
a special education facility
unfortunately fortunately for many
children who require scn there are no
special educational need Provisions
within Rochford District the applicant's
child would need to travel back to
Wickford bason or chelsford to access
the senn schools if this location were
chosen for the child's education
purposes residents question if indeed it
is in the child's best interest would a
better location be more
suitable page 8.13 paragraph
2.31 it goes on to explain the
applicants child health conditions
require trips to London Hospital
likewise the settled Community under the
equality act would should also be given
the same weight like Mrs bellin's
daughter Maisy who also visits the
London Hospital for her Leukemia
treatment members are not furnished with
the personal medical details information
regard regarding the applicant's
children therefore it's extremely
difficult to determine a balanced
view however the needs of the applicant
do does not outweigh the harm to the
greenbell and to the health of one of
the residents of the settled
Community page
8.14
2.34 the paragraph 13 National planning
policy for travel sites promotes a
peaceful and integrated coexistence
between site and the local community can
I ask members those able to visit the
site and adjoining residents do you
believe a peaceful and integrated
coexistence with the local community is
achievable or is this Council setting
this Arrangement up for the fail failure
policy C regarding sites in rural areas
and Countryside paragraph 14 states that
when assessing the suitability of sites
in Rural and semi-rural settings
local planning authorities should ensure
that the scale of such sites does not
dominate the nearest settled
Community the scale of the 12 children
and four adults will most certainly
likely to dominate the nearest community
bashier volume and the acoustic noise
ultimately counselors you're being
forced to make a binary choice between
the family already settled with severe
Health considerations evidenced by high
court protection deputies social workers
or the applicant whose children also
have special Health considerations to
Warrant the green belt change of use the
committee are asked to consider the
needs of the child are you sure this is
the best place to park the
Caravans the flood zone high high to
medium risk residents have provided
photos of the flooding in their Gardens
as displayed on the the overhead there
um the drainage strategy sub was not
submitted by the applicant um the
managing director of a prime flow
drainage and plumbing services limited
assessment was carried out and provided
a report which coun please the explore
to explore the possibility of the
Drainage Field on behalf of their family
at DOR Lodge members if a drainage
assessment was not aailable meters away
from the plot bearing in mind the
rainfall that comes down the hill you
must question the feasibility only
meters away for the applicant I strongly
recommend this application is deferred
until proven that the plot can pass the
sequential test okay you're well past
time now I'm going to have to ask you to
conclude thank you thank you very
much
okay thank you as with everyone else
you have five minutes and I'll let you
know when the one minute time comes
up as a new counselor I remain confused
and Collex at why the severe needs of
the young man at dork Lodge do not seem
to have adequately been taken into
account when recommending this
application we have heard that this
young man has profound needs having been
given protection by the court with full
legal
representation and therefore high levels
of
vulnerability I would urge to make urge
the committee to ensure his needs are
given the highest
regard I have begun to learn so many
decisions that we make as councilors are
difficult and undoubtedly inherent in
this decision on this application there
is complexity intensity and difficulty
however it comes down to a question of
balance
we have been informed that D Lodge was
chosen as a residence by this young
man's legal team and family for its
relative quietness Tranquility in a semi
rural location in the green
belt his needs are currently being met
in part by its locality and relative
secluded he has begun to engage with the
local
community however there are legitimate
concerns that the proposed development
right next door to dor Lodge would only
increase his vulnerabilities fail to
meet his needs escalating his anxiety
distress and causing unfathomable
confusion I am not fully conversant with
the intricacies of the equality Act of
2010 but understand quite rightly that
both sides of the argument will be cited
it to support their
views but what I do understand and
believe in passionately is that society
and Community can be judged by the way
it supports nurtures and cares for the
most vulnerable in
society I sought election in May for
this very purpose and I have come to
learn so many of my colleagues sitting
in this room
tonight no matter of their political
views or their political party share
such a
passion to accept this application
putting the needs of some over the needs
of a vulnerable young man who has been
resident for three years and has the
protection of the court I believe would
circumvent any understanding of natural
Justice and I would implore this
committee on this dark late evening in
September to not approve this
application thereby giving this young
person his family and legal
Representatives peace peace they've had
to fight for for far too often for far
too long and far too hard peace to
continue with the life they have come to
love peace to continue to engage with
the community in which they feel
safe peace for this young man to grow up
to be all that he can
be I'd like to thank this opportunity
for the chair allowing me to speak as
the new boy on the council after more my
more senior
colleagues I ask your forgiveness if
what I have expressed could Beed
perceive to some by being as
emotive but I just like to end with a
quote one ought to hold one's heart but
if one lets it go one soon loses control
of the Hedge
too councelor Mason and councelor
Gooding have asked the committee to use
your
heads I would ask that you also use your
hearts thank you for this opportunity to
[Applause]
speak
would any other visiting me Members like
to speak on this
item
no okay thank you right so we move on to
members of the committee I believe
councelor Foster you
first thank you
chairman I'm referring to the addendum
um in page 12 section two the offical
response to Mrs Spain refers to the
public sector equalities act on page 13
2.5 it states that persons with
disabilities are required to be
considered by the psed I'm going to
follow up this some points on page 13.
2.6 and page 14 2.8 it twice
acknowledges potential impact on Mrs
Spain's sum but states that these claims
have not been substantiated I'm going to
say more about that in a moment it goes
on to say in 2.8 that there are
mitigating considerations that would
lessen the
impact on Mrs Spain son it provides no
evidence to substantiate that claim that
the mitigating considerations would
lessen the
impact it seems that great weight has
been given to the special circumstances
of the applicant but special
circumstances for K Spain seem to have
been
overlooked moving on to substantive
impact of on on Kai in its objection
letter of the 14th of July solicitors
acting on behalf of Kai's court
appointed Deputy apart from identifying
planning reasons invited planners to
have a confidential discussion with
regard to Kai's physical and mental
disabilities my question did a
discussion take place and if so did that
get reflected in the
report in its letter of 31st of August
the court appointed Deputy highlighted
Kai's issues and objected to the
application
what is the reaction to that
letter in a letter dated yesterday and
received today from Kai's brain injury
case manager an independent social
worker I should add that Mrs Spain gave
me permission to mention these
conditions um the uh brain injury case
manager and independent social worker
makes a strong case that any development
in the immediate vicinity of dor Lodge
is likely to negatively impact Kai's
anxiety
self-confidence and
well-being have officers seen this and
if so what is your
reaction apparently if I reflect on
these points it would seem to me that
the requirements of the pcscd in
relation to
um considering the impact on
disabilities have have not actually been
considered in the case of
K moving on on page 14 Point 2.7 the
report compares the application site
with an existing residential dwelling
saying it would share a similar
relationship to that between dor clge
and the application site that's hardly a
real realistic comparison a
three-bedroomed house with four adults
compared with two static Caravans two
day rooms and 16 occupants 12 of whom
are
children also in 2.7 it questions
whether the characteristics of the
application site were fundamental to the
purchase to dor Lodge the letter datting
the 31st of August from the solicitors
Thompson Snell and pasmore the appointed
Deputy makes it clear that the property
was chosen due to its rural green belt
location it also states that it's
unclear why steps would have not been
taken the report says it's unclear why
steps have not been taken to secure
characteristics in purp these
characteristics imp
perpetuity I would suggest it's not a
reasonable assumption that the local
Authority is it not a reasonable
assumption that the local Authority
should take those steps to protect the
green belt not the buyer the resident
buying a property as an aside Mrs Spain
did try to buy Pro the land but was out
building an
auction reection 3.1 the consultation
response from the ECC Highway Authority
the response only considers exiting the
Minor Road onto the highway explain good
visibility however entering the Minor
Road has not been considered coming from
from the direction of the Railway Bridge
turning left into magnoli road is a
blind turning with of about
180° I've witnessed near misses there
why did the highways Authority only
offer an opinion on exiting Magnolia
Road apart from that they did not
consider the private road understandably
and I would argue that the narrowness of
Magnolia and Lincoln roads is
inappropriate for construction traffic
and Caravan traffic in section 4.1 it
talks of condition 8 stating that prior
to installation of front access gate has
been agreed by the planning Authority in
writing the gate's already been changed
was it agreed by officers or has it been
done before
approval um re item 7.1 and I think this
quite important the vehicle size
condition which allows one vehicle of up
to 7.5 tons in weight and now other
vehicle over 3.5 tons 7.5 tons include
small two axle lores up to 3.5 tons can
include commercial vehicles such as
pickup trucks so my questions are does
the
applicant intend to use the site as a
business base how many vehicles will be
accommodated on the hard standing and
bear in mind there proposed to be two
family pitches do these conditions apply
to each family pitch I.E there'd be two
7.5 ton lores potentially on the
side in the original report for
tonight's meeting I needed to be winding
up please page 8.18 I'm almost there
item 2.6 it responds to increase in
noise that would result from formation
of two additional households the
response in report States the
development of two pitches not would not
have any greater impact upon noise from
the Pres than the presence of a two
brick mortar buildings so I suggest that
comparison is irrelevant but I'll be
correct in saying if there were bricks
and Water application it would be
rejected thank
you thank you I think at this point I
think it would
be at this point I think it'd be remiss
of me not to refer back to Katie there
are a number of issues that have been
raised that I think uh would be useful
to have response thank you thank you
chairman if I've missed any of the
points please feel free to repeat
questions um so hopefully going in
reverse order the condition would apply
to both pitches um we haven't restricted
the number of vehicles that would be uh
allowed to be kept on the site it is
only proposed for residential use
um so we would expect that it would be
reflective of
that um and so I guess that in part
answers your other question about
whether it would be used for commercial
there isn't a proposal on the table for
commercial um you had made a point
around the the S6 County Council had
only considered the exiting of the Minor
Road rather than the entering of the
Minor Road um but their Collision data
shows that there is no record of a
collision in on that Junction for the
past 5 years exiting or
entering um you had asked if officers
had seen the letters that had been
submitted by uh the solicitor and the
social worker we'd only been sent these
by counselors over the past 24 hours
which is why the addendum does not speak
to those we were not given sight of them
beforehand
nevertheless the considerations in the
officer report so that includes the
characteristics of the site so the dense
and substantial veg ation together with
the fact that it's a residential use
adjacent to a residential use um and
then the best interest of the child of
the applicant and the lack of the Gypsy
and traveler sites within the district
mean that the planning balance considers
the application
acceptable um so the original solicitor
letter invited officers to approach them
to ask for medical letters and we sought
legal advice on that and we were told it
was not necessary sorry told it was not
necessary yes okay um I think that was
all your questions but if I've missed
any please feel free to repeat them um I
said there's no evidence uh supporting
the claim that the mitigating
considerations would lessen the impact
on
Kai and on the um
uh the letter from the court appointed
Deputy I asked what's the reaction to
that
letter I think I just answered that one
so that that's for those mitigation
measures I've said and there isn't a
evidence that we can give for mitigation
measures it comes down to planning
balance so officers have considered that
those factors do account for mitigation
but obviously members of the committee
can disagree with that
view okay
[Music]
um okay I think that's answered the
questions to some extent uh what I'd
like to do is move for
refusal on the grounds that the special
circumstances of the disabilities of K
Spain Spain have not been properly
considered and there are some other
points that would make in relation to
the proposed uh
refusal one is that the highway
assessments did not consider all aspects
of the junction with retory
Road uh also obviously Magnolia and
Lincoln Road um being private roads did
not get included and my view is there
are inappropriate access for
construction and Caravan traffic
um the comparison between the
relationship of the application on dor
Lodge and that of existing neighbors is
speculative in the report the fact that
the deputy did not take reasonable steps
to secure the green belt application
site in perpetuity is not a reasonable
ground to approve the
application the report dismisses the
noise concern based on the Assumption or
the
presumption uh of the suggested
mitigation being
effective um I suggest in line with the
comments
earlier inappropriate development on the
green
belt and um I think that's the
list so taking into those consideration
all the circumstances and the supporting
evidence uh it would be reasonable to
put forward that motion to refuse the
planning
application thank you
chairman uh Council FY is second and and
um I think at this point we need to uh
ask for legal clarification please sry
could you just go through those reasons
again please councelor fost uh yes I
said to start with bearing in mind the
comment about the um at the start the
requirement in the public C sector
equalities act so my first point was I
move the refusal on the grounds that in
line with the public sector equalities
act special circumstances of the
disabilities of kis Bain have not been
properly
considered secondly the highway
assessment did not consider all aspects
of the junction with retri Road and
clearly because it's a private road it
did not consider that Magnolia and
Lincoln Road provide inappropriate
access for construction and Caravan
traffic um there are points used to uh
in the officers recommend mational
approval Mak a comparison between
relationship of the application on dor
Lodge and that of existing neighbors are
speculative um the fact that also in the
officer report uh it this point about
the perpetuity the fact that the deputy
appointed to look after Kai's interest
did not take reasonable steps to secure
secure the green belt application site
in perpetuity is not a reasonable ground
to approve the
application the report dismisses the
noise concern based on the Assumption of
the
presumption U of suggested
mitigation I emphasiz emphasize word
presumption based on the Assumption
presumption that the suggested
mitigation would be
effective and also it would be an
inappropriate development in the green
belt for the points that have been made
in earlier Pres earlier
speeches Jes can I have
your opinion on those
please I should clarify I did maybe I
didn't make that quite clear that the
the Lincoln Road Magnolia Road represent
an
unsatisfactory inappropriate access for
construction and Caravan
traffic
thank you
chairman
okay and now you understand my
observations at this
point are concerned with the lawfulness
of the proposed reasons not not their
merits you understand so I'm not I'm not
saying whether I think they're good or
bad reasons but I'm commenting on
whether they are reasons which you can
lawfully apply may I respond in that the
points that I'm responding to as reasons
were made in the officer's report in
support of the application yeah yeah
okay so if they're not valid planning
reasons they weren't valid planning
reasons when the officers made the
report so the first
one I'm not sure it's lawful I'm not
sure it's a planning
reason to say you're refusing permission
for this proposal because of the
particular circumstances of an
individual now it may
be that your point is and the discussion
has centered on
this the
disturbance which you judge will arise
from the site is unacceptable so it
maybe that could be articulated as a an
impact on the immunity of
existing neighboring
properties
reason could I sorry well let me finish
then you can come
back the second point about Highway
assessment I think there were two
aspects I think you were if I understood
properly was saying there there's been
an inadequate Highway assessment and
also that the access in your judgment is
inadequate for
construction and Caravan traffic that's
the unmade SE yeah that that could be
articulated with reference to policy I'm
sure that is uh
lawful the the
point
I think the the third point was you were
saying well the officer compares the
relationship between dor Lodge and
another house to the north as being
comparable I think that's
really I think that would have to be
articulated in the first reason as as an
amenity
one it's it's the officer is making an
illustrative point she's not saying it
should be refused because it's you know
something similar she's just making the
point that the distance between the two
properties is is the same so I think if
we could fold that into the first reason
about impact on amenity and existing
properties I think that that would be
that would be
um the third sorry the fourth
reason um again I think you the point
you were making was that the cour of
protection didn't seek
to secure the property in
perpetuity
um I don't think I don't think we can
articulate that as a reason for
refusal in planning
terms wait I'll finish
noise
um yes that that is it's it's a it's a
lawful reason if you
judge that no I mean it's
it's not a million miles away from the
impact on immunity reason but if you're
saying that the noise
generated from the proposed site will
have an unacceptable impact on
neighbors um I mean there's no evidence
of that I've got got to warn
you and then the final one inappropriate
development in the green belt and very
special circumstances haven't been
met that's that's perfectly lawful
planning
reason so I think
immunity is lawful
highways sorry immunity SL noise put it
put it that way so grow it together
highways
and green belt very special
circumstances are capable of being
articulated as
lawful planning reasons for
refusal and again I don't I don't make
well I I do make some comments I don't
think they' be very easy to defend but
they are lawful okay can I respond to a
couple of the points certainly um the
reason I mentioned the Imp perpetuity
thing and the fact of the that not being
protected through the um the uh legal
process I mention that in particular
because in the officer report it makes
the point that the Mrs
bellain and the U and the legal process
should perhaps have uh triy to
acquire that piece of green belt land to
protect it from it's not what the are
saying sorry my understanding is that
she did try
so I don't think
that's a substantial reason so why was
it in the
report okay now just to keep a bit of
order here um we are now talking to the
motion um so if we can bear that in mind
councilor
Myers
the only thing that seems to been left
off a council fil's list is the fact
that site is susceptible to flooding on
quite a regular basis it surely must be
a planning
consideration yes you've you've heard
from
the um applicant that the Caravans are
located in part of the site which
doesn't suffer from flooding and there's
no objection from um the flooding
authorities but it is capable of being a
planning reason of refusal
yes I mean you understand the difference
you can what I'm trying to establish is
that these reasons are lawful not that
they're
necessarily going to succeed on appeal
but okay I'm aware there are quite a few
members who want to speak but I need to
go back to Katie first please I just
wanted to clarify that there's surface
water flood risk not flood risk from
fluvio or Coastal s
so you may want to specify that it's
surface flood risk that you have an
objection to what I would say is that we
are able to condition um and it will
impose a condition which deals with
surface water flood risk and that is
something that we have done on other
sides but obviously is up to members
whether or not you feel that that is
you're comfortable to do that on this
occasion are we okay with adding that in
yeah okay so that is so uh Council Alman
I believe you were
first thank you chairman um it's been a
full night and I've listen to what the
officer said and and I did get it twice
from the gentleman representing the uh
applicant again and again so I just want
to reate re see mention my point in all
of this is that we can go on about
planning consent as just interrup you
this sry we're talking to the motion
yeah I was I was thinking about adding
another okay Amendment but I wanted to
explain it before you otherwise I'll
just give you the words carry on the
thing is that right from the outset of
this right from the outset the the point
was made to us about equality equality
being an important issue in all of this
and I've got to say I'm really
unfortunately I don't think that there's
been a case in this so if we look back
on I just want to bring this up when
considering any planning application
planning authorities should ensure the
substantial weight is given it goes on
very special circumstances will not
exist unless the potential harm to the
green belt by reason the progress and
any other harm resulting from The
Proposal clearly outweighs by other
considerations now I've listened to
everything I TR being partial to this
and I my view on all of this is not
necessary about all the planning issues
it's about this issue about special
circumstances and I'm afraid I've
listened to all science and we've had
the opportunity and I'm grateful for it
of being told about private matters
and having heard that and listened to
everything else I think personally that
all the circumstances that have been put
forward have not in my opinion U raised
an argument of very special
circumstances the balance for me is
completely one-sided and I don't think
it's right that we you know we've got an
inappropriate development due to special
circumstances that have not been met so
what my what I'm trying to do to is
saying that I would like to add that
that inappropriate development due to
the special circumstan not being met but
the reason for that is because listening
to what everything has been said and I'm
not going to go into it because it's
been said so many times by so many
people that I just don't think that we
are in a position to go beyond that very
special
circumstances uh and I think it fails at
the first goalpost the first Ur that's
my opinion Charles come back that's
that's captured by the the third
reason which we went through yeah I just
wanted to add to that because I think
that's very important yeah the very
special circumstance so we we know that
the development is inappropriate in the
green belt that's not an issue it's your
judgment various raal circumstances
hav't I'm trying to explain why I think
they haven't been met and I and it's
about equality and and I think that
that's why I'm saying what I'm
saying sorry could I say chair the
special circumstances discussion my
point was that whatever special
circumstances there were on the side of
the applicant have been made clear but
the weight of the special circumstances
on the part of Mrs Spain and our family
have not been made clear and I just
would like if special circumstances or a
waiting factor in the approval of a
planning permission in the green bill
then both sides of that story need to be
understood and the imp on Mrs span and
Kai is massive yeah I think we've
actually now um established that that is
the the committee's feeling on that
particular one so we don't need to
actually go over that again but I'm
aware C Council coun I believe you
wanted to speak thank you Mr chairman
I've got a question for the officer
which will affect obviously how I vote
and it may affect some of the others but
um can you CL clarify if the application
did not have a child with a medical
condition would the officer still be
recommending this application for
approval or not does it hinge on the
child special needs or not are you
referring to the applicants yes so
planning National planning policy for
traveler sites is clear that subject to
the best interest of the child the other
personal circumstances may not outweigh
the harm to the green belt so if there
were not children on this site that's
subject to the best interest of the
child would not be triggered so that is
say essentially saying that the those
other personal circumstances may not
outweigh harm to the green belt but best
interest the child do because they are a
primary consideration so it's not that
the child has medical concerns as in the
applicant it's that they are a child is
that
clear yes it's it's um it's sort of
clear but um what you're saying is one
child's needs outweigh another child's
needs um so it's it's quite balanc in
act for this committee to have to make
those decisions on that basis they
different legislative matters Jes will
probably be able to speak on this better
it it's it's certainly all about balance
and just just a um slight a slight
inflection on on
what what KY said the personal
circumstances of the applicants family
are policy tells tell us you have to
take into consideration and that
includes in this case any medical
conditions which any of the children
might um suffer
from uh separate to that there is now
this preeminent consideration which you
must keep in the Forefront of your mind
the best interest of the children if
there are children who as a result of
this
decision uh would have to go and live by
the side of the road or doubling up on
somebody else's site that can that's
what the best interest of Child mean now
it's all about it isn't a it isn't a
straightforward formula that if you have
the best interest of child that
necessarily outweighs any harm to the
green belt it's all a balance for your
judgment but what the best interest of a
child means it's not something you can
um nothing else can be given more
prominence in your decision making but
that doesn't mean that always leads to
the
same outcome the same conclusion do you
understand that but you're you're
absolutely right it is a matter of
balance and it's it's it's difficult I
know because you're
balancing not just apples and pears
apples pears potatoes you know carrots
you know all pulling in different
directions and that's that's the task
which you have to do as a committee and
it is
difficult okay thank you Jo um I believe
councelor Mrs Newport do you wanted to
say
something thank you chair so correct me
if I'm wrong I just want to understand
so we need to give weight to the
applicant special needs and special
needs because there's a child we need to
put their best interest at
heart but not to the settled resident
that has special needs special medical
needs we don't need to give wait to
that there are two separate things
which are both in play in this case so
there's the best interest of the child
and that means because that's what the
guidance tells us the best interest of
the child of the
applicant the the children of the
families who' be living on the side
there's also the public sector equality
Duty which is what councilor Foster was
talking about now that's because Kai we
know has a disability so he is subject
so in making the decision you members of
the of the council must keep in mind
your duties under the public sector
equality Duty which are summarized very
well in
Kat's um second
addendum on page 12 and
13 but what she's saying
is
yes there is a situation here where Kai
has particular vulnerabilities to noise
and
disturbance uh but she's saying that's
the top of page
14 the distance between the boundary of
the site and dor Lodge is 8 and 1 half
mters and then it's a further
16.8 m to the house and between so
that's 30 now it's 24 25
M and between the site and dor Lodge KY
lips there's a thick Dent band of
vegetation which will remain so the
officer's judgment
is that that means there isn't in
reality going to be much disturbance
from the site because of the layout
because of the distance and because and
because of the density of the vegetation
in between now you're entitled to reach
a different judgment about that and it
sounds like that that's what you you you
have from from the questions youve
raised but that's how the public sector
equality Duty in this case applies so
it's not being ignored but I think what
the officer is saying the layout of the
site and I think that's probably why
she's she's made the
comparable observations about another
property about equivalent distance so
can I come can I come back if I may so
it's because of the distance between the
applicant residents proposed residents
and Mrs or Mrs Bain's residence because
of that distance we don't really need to
give as much consideration to Kai's
situation you give it consider in in in
terms of what we can refuse or
accept the proposal on you as I said the
officer is saying well that's quite a
big distance with a big thick band of
vegetation so the impact the officer's
judgment isn't going to be that great on
Kai you're entitled to reach a different
conclusion having heard from Miss Mrs
Miss Bain and say well no given his
sensitivities it's likely he would be
disturbed so you different way on
members can I say thatman that was
opinion not evidence just a minute can I
the officers minute um time is marching
on I I mindful that I do want to get uh
members to make every observation that
they can but I am also mindful of the
time um so I will I believe I've got
three uh members who want to speak and
then I think we need to go to the vote
so I start off with councilor
refy thank you chairman um very
difficult decision to make planning loss
is one way and
moral and hearts is another way but
where it comes down to with the from the
officer and what I've heard here tonight
is
the the legal team of Kai offered to
talk to the officer the officer as they
normally do take legal advice and legal
advice was not to talk to them and I
think that is not being
fair and that is why I'm I don't think I
can support this because I don't think
the officer is a planning officer she's
not a medical expert to make these
decisions is 8 and a half meters far
enough away I think their team should
have been talked to and actually got
proper advice from his people who know
him thank
you okay uh councilor
[Applause]
Laur than chair very briefly I agree
with that but uh I just wanted to point
out the 28 meter I don't know if you do
a bit of swimming but it's only about a
width of a an Olympic swimming pool and
then they' got six meters and these
bushes do die they're not like a brick
wall or a screen they're just bushes so
but I'll go back to the point that I
think I do think it's been a bias report
personally is my opinion but the thing
is that um I still come back to the
point that we should take looking at the
thing of equality and special
circumstances has to outweigh one team
or the other and um I think it failed
basically thank you okay thank you
Council Council
[Applause]
Ward thank you very much chairman um I
just want to go to policy now I think
that's going to be more important if I
can um policy dm1 our own the design of
new development should promote the
character of the locality to ensure that
development positively contributes to
the surrounding natural and built
environment and residential
amenity without discouraging originality
Innovation or initiative can I interrupt
there can are you pres proposing because
we are talking to the um the motion we
are are are you proposing an addition to
it is that the is that what you're doing
I I am looking towards something to
strengthen the reasons that have already
given so you're looking for an addition
yes I am okay thank you very much
chairman
so in dm1 point 10 a positive
relationship with existing and nearby
buildings in accordance with policy dm3
which I'll come to and and 11 on dm1 a
scale and form appropriate to the
locality in line with policy
dm3 now need to quote
dm3 proposals for infilling residential
intensification or backland development
must demonstrate that the following have
been carefully considered Ed and
positively assessed and item four an
assessment of the proposal's impact on
residential immunity and I think that's
a very very big point that has been made
by councilor
Foster point five avoiding a detrimental
impact on landscape character or or
historic
environment and six avoiding the loss of
import
open space which provides a community
benefit and or visual focus in the
street scene so it provides Community
benefit and I think those items are very
very relevant to the neighborhood of dor
Lodge and this new application so then
can I pry that to inclusion of policy
dm1 uh10 DM 3.4 and five
is that right it's dm3
yeah it's it's uh four five and six four
five and six okay uh
Charles I don't have to B this in front
of me but they presumbly sort of General
design policies or yeah but that well
that's it's
lawful thank you okay so in so so we can
wind this up yeah I think we're okay on
that because that we picked up on in
in yeah before before we actually um I
would ask councelor Foster to go over
his uh res for refusal again so we're
all very clear but before we do that I
would like to ask Katie to respond
please thank you sorry I just wanted to
clarify whether that was an additional
reason for refusal you were adding it to
an previous one
mentioned additional yes okay thank
you okay Council fost you agreeable with
that yeah yeah okay so that'll be added
to your uh motion for refusal can you
now uh go through the um uh the reasons
for refusal so as we are clear what we
are voting on
please you mind you I do that yes I can
i' ask G's help reformulated some of
them into
and again like with the previous
decision these will have to be
articulated the next day or two first
one is
essentially impact on
immunity of neighboring properties
particular reference to
noise the second one is a
highways It's a combination of
inadequate assessment plus poor
access
third
one which should probably be the first
reason is um inappropriate development
in the green belt very special
circumstances not
established the fourth one is
surface
flooding and the fifth one is the um
essentially the the design appearance um
based on policies d one and
three if that's what those policies
are I believe the ones that we were
looking at was
dm110 and
dm3 uh 4.5 and6 yeah so they're parts of
D3 okay could I chairman could I just go
back to the um special circumstance
discussion in the sense in the sense
that the way GES has described that rep
relates to the special circumstance
purely the applicant it
doesn't pick up the fact that the
officers had not properly considered the
special circumstance of the people
opposing it because the uh the act the
PPS public sector equalities act talks
about persons with disabilities and that
includes people at both sides of the
argument it doesn't say appli just to
AB the um
the officer
has considered it in detail in the
recent
addendum um but your
committee's I'm I'm sensing the
committee doesn't accept the advice
about the distance and the separation so
it can't be said it hasn't been
considered you've just reached a
different conclusion than the
recommendation of your officer or I
expect you will shortly
you wanted to say something chair thank
you um very briefly members I think the
point that's been made here regarding
having a difference of opinion and
disagreeing with the report and on
balance whereby the committee is coming
to a particular decision is perfectly
reasonable as has been explained I don't
think it's reasonable to suggest that
there are elements of bi within the
report so I want to make that clear that
ultimately this is a disagreement in
terms of balancing those planning
reasons thank you right I think we're at
a position now where I think we need to
vote we have had the um reasons for
refusal clarified to us so uh all those
in favor of the reasons for refusal
please
indicate oh sorry I need a second down
yeah it has been it has been seconded
yeah yeah sorry yeah uh so uh please
would you indicate if you are uh in
favor of the reasons for
refusal okay that is unanimous so uh
[Applause]
that that item is is now uh closed so we
have one more item to uh consider very
quickly item nine items referred from
the weekly list members there are
none so um with that thank you very much
for your endurance tonight
everybody the meeting is closed
at
1131 11:30 thank you
m